[Musique]
j'ai pas venu au studio pour mais
paralysé explique sur un gros but en
direct de paname un peu comme ça dans le
jeu les martyriser à dire ça ne passait
j'écris souvent eh ouais je rappelle
qu'ils pèsent sur le côté dans la fente
innover les tartines et mouchard enterré
il ya pas un dîner raconte ma vie les
petits trucs et sont autour de moi le
truc que je remarque qu'en général le
rap français a vécu une évolution
incroyable et fait partie de nos vies à
tous maintenant parce que du rap y en a
pour tous les goûts
ah ouais m'enfin star scène le rappeur
préféré avec booba rohff la mafia k 1
fry moi j'écoute du rap j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup écouté
ntm une chaîne aussi en solo aiamc james
beaucoup plus l'ancienne génération que
la nouvelle je peux pas mentir
moi je suis pas trop rap moi je suis
ouais donc c'est à dire je tournais la
série je découvrais un monde un peu je
suis plutôt wright voix je suis
sentimentale je l'aï jamais dit ça va
pas je mets un peu cheap khaled se
relève directeur c'est merci 2008 non
c'est un morceau de ntm et c'est alex de
kool shen qui dit nous censure parce que
notre culture est trop basanée
représentent pas assez la france du
passé
donc on rappait dans les mjc ça allait
mais aujourd'hui le phénomène a grandi
dieu merci et puniques sa merci on passe
pas dans leur radio l'essentiel c'était
de sortir de la cave et les gens le
savent mais le gars n'a pas su organiser
un concert sauvage gratuit au moment où
j'écoutais du a effectivement on rappe
et ça les mecs rappelle le fait que
qu'on n'était pas invitée dans les
émissions de télé que ça passait pas en
radio maintenant maître gims rempli le
stade de france soprano rempli de stade
vélodrome d'un coup le rap est devenue
la première musique de france et moi
j'ai complètement assister à cette
consultation là donc je me sens un peu
militant et validé c'est c'est la
continuité logique de l'évolution du rap
en france
c'est pour ça que valider ne peut pas
être une série comme les autres je crois
que jamais personne qu'après un truc
pareil tf1 première fois la seule
complexité était de se dire comment on
fait pour le personnage de apache et
pour le personnage de ma star puisque
tous les deux sont des rappeurs comment
on fait pour que ça ressemble pas
forcément à ce qu'ils font eux comme
style da et ça a été mais première mes
premières discussions avec moussa qui
joue masta et avec les mots qui joua
page c'est légal il faut pas que ça
ressemble à ce que vous faites vous
ceux-là
l'europe de ma star tu veux c'est ça
rappe qui a su s'adapter au fil des
années parce qu'on sent que voilà il est
pile et il est pas jeunes comme un
clément ou comme un
un carnage et on sent que c'est genre
d'artiste qui justement comme on dit
dans le milieu a vécu l'âge d'or mais
qui a su s'adapter et qui assez
polyvalent qui sait faire tous types de
sons il a l'oreille musicale pour faire
les sons qui puisse plaire justement au
public et apache c'est ça ap lma
appartement type et c'est leur carte au
trésor
est ce qu'une différence entre ath ikea
passe dans le rap rémy forcément parce
que prison pour mineurs je n'aurais pas
écrit
c'est une histoire d'un patch est pas
l'histoire des tic suis dans le big four
à tron me pas taper dur et âpre est
clairement dans la fusée ça aurait pu
être un titre que je regardais pour mon
projet parce que racontent les textes
d'apache c'est principalement c'est sa
vie en fait de manière générale et c'est
à la fois sa vie de manière plus
sensible et touchante comme sur prison
pour mineurs tout comme ça peut être
plus un truc de d'attitude de temps je
suis là quoi je suis charismatique et je
vais le montrer en fait c'est ça c'est
vraiment l'exercice d'ego tripes
[Musique]
et jaune pour le regard clément la scène
qu'on va tourner aujourd'hui c'est la
scène où j'arrive j'allais dans un
studio de fou malade avec mon rapport
préférés et je vis un rêve et rire
aujourd'hui d'avoir des planches rap et
tout ça va être vraiment bien je pense
ok j'arrête inquiet comme un braqueur de
banque pop art consiste à donner des
solutions durables apache girex un rap
qui est moderne mais empreint de tout un
bagage culturel rap classique plusieurs
school lui permet d'être à la fois
pertinent pour les anciens mais d'avoir
l'énergie et la fraîcheur des des gens
de son âge est ce que tu veux que je
fasse un truc de boxer pour un truc de
mec est là comme ça à moi même si je
vais rentrer pour un morceau qui est
très très sensible touchant et tout ça
reste la bagarre la recherche de la
performance boxer avant une prise comme
comme on peut le voir sur le making-of
en fait pour moi c'est juste un moyen de
relâcher la pression et c'est un
sentiment de de lâcher prise en fait
quand on sait de la respiration aussi et
puis avant de monter sur scène c'est
aussi mon rituel donc que ce soit avant
le actions ou avant le
je début d'un cancer ce qui tend à
valider une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal